claramente las declaraciones de arturo
mcfields tomaron por sorpresa hoy al
gobierno de daniel ortega y de rosario
murillo en nicaragua porque hasta hace
tan solo dos días lo mencionaban como su
embajador ante la oea en una publicación
cultural adherida al gobierno
nicaragüense pero hoy lo despojaron de
ese título por medio de una nota de
prensa emitida por el ministerio de
relaciones exteriores en la que se lee
que el representante nicaragüense ante
el organismo de estados americanos es
francisco camps el booker y que lo dicho
por maxfield no tiene validez y que fue
lo dicho por arturo mcfields en esta
sesión permanente de la oea básicamente
que nicaragua la dupla de ortega murillo
es una dictadura que en su país no hay
organismos de derechos humanos que las
elecciones no son creíbles y que no hay
partidos de oposición y lo dijo en
nombre de más de 177 presos políticos y
en nombre de más de 350 personas que han
perdido la vida en el marco de
represiones gubernamentales desde el
2018 el secretario general de la oea
celebró su valentía y además le ofreció
protección al tiempo que varias voces
opositores aplaudía en su coraje
recordemos que desde noviembre de 2000
21 nicaragua decidió retirarse
permanentemente de la oea un hecho un
proceso que tomará dos años y esto
después de que el organismo desconociera
esas elecciones controversiales en las
cuales daniel ortega y rosario murillo
se hicieron a un quinto mandato al
frente de los nicaragüenses